hello this is richard zheng 2010
National Geographic be representative
for New York State in this video my
brother Jerry will be asking me a few
questions that I will answer if someone
gives you a free ticket to travel
anywhere in the world where would you go
tell us what you would do all you would
dare and why you picked it I would
travel to Sydney Australia because I've
never actually been south of the Equator
before I would also like to visit the
Sydney Opera House how do you smush all
that information and nose into your
brain what's the secret sure whenever
stay tipsy tricks well instead of
cramming right before to be I try to
split my study time evenly over the
course of many weeks this allows me to
memorize more a lot more if we put you
in charge of the earth for entire day
what's the very first problem or a few a
tackle what will you do I would try to
tackle racism as world leader I would
appreciate quality to the whole world
share one weird but true or an in fact
you've earned um more ets is the only
country besides Nepal and India to have
a Hindu majority and this concludes my
video thank you for watching
you